je ne sais pas bien comment on commence
son tedx
quel mode accroche quelle blague quel
ton je vous avoue que là je suis un peu
paumé comme pour tous les débuts je ne
sais jamais trop par où commencer
ça fait peur la nouveauté quand on ne
sait pas choisir une orientation partir
à l'aventuré commencé une nouvelle
relation amoureuse ou lancer un projet
face à la nouveauté sont plonge dans le
vide soit on s'immobilise par la peur
est là j'ai peur d'être en face de vous
on dirait peut-être pas comme ça mais je
suis assez tétanisé
pourtant plus j'ai peur plus j'ai envie
d'y aller c'est assez paradoxal mais
c'est sûrement pour ça que je suis en
face de vous aujourd'hui
pour vous dire haut et fort d'y aller de
ne pas attendre de cultiver vos rêves de
cultiver cette âme d'enfant qui rêvent
plus grands qui agit avec spontanéité et
qui arrange les peurs aux plaques
alors voilà c'est dit je pourrais
m'arrêter là mon message est passé et on
m'a dit que pour faire un bon tedx il
fallait un message clair
et ça serait trop simple et surtout je
sais bien que c'est plus facile à dire
qu'à faire c'est aux ont maintenant
cultiver sa confiance personnelle avoir
le goût du risque tout ça tout ça on les
entend partout même si c'était simple
comme s'il suffisait de le dire
mais non j'ai pris du temps à comprendre
ses mots et à les mettre en action et je
sais pas vous mais ces gens là qui me
disait dit croire en moi même je n'avais
pas confiance en moi je n'arrivais pas à
les croire je me disais qu'ils avaient
eu de la chance eux et que ça n'était
pas pour moi j'ai pris du temps à
cultiver ma confiance personnelle à
m'émanciper et à oser vivre une vie et
les autres ne comprennent pas
à 18 ans je suis parti en inde et par la
force des choses j'ai arrêté d'essayer
de tout contrôler et de brosser ma
différence
j'ai compris que c'était l'action
il faisait barrière hopper et que
plonger dans l'inconnu prendre la route
la moins sûre et skis nous réserver de
plus belle surprise
alors de ce jour plus rien de m'arrêter
j'ai créé mon podcast nouvel oeil qui
deux ans après son lancement cumul et
centaines de milliers d coûte près de
100 interview j'ai écrit un livre et je
les publier je donne des conférences
partout en france pour éveiller les
jeunes et je fais des concerts aussi
s'il ya deux ans on m'avait dit que j'en
serai là il n'y aurait pas cru je ne me
serais senti ni capable ni légitime
pourtant tout ça n'est pas tombée du
ciel ça n'est que le fruit de l'action
de la persévérance et de beaucoup
d'audace
dans une société qui nous pousse à être
la copie conforme de notre voisin
j'ai décidé d'être moi
juste moi en jaune est en folie
en étant moi même j'ai cultivé une forme
d'urgence à réparer le monde
alors non promis ça ne sera pas un
énième ted sur l'urgence écologique et
le monde qui se défait je préfère
éveillé qu'effrayer alors j'espère
cultivées en vous dans ce temps qui
m'est imparti beaucoup d'espoir et
l'envié furieuse réaliser vos rêves
je m'appelle victoria j'ai 23 ans j'ai
grandi au milieu des vaches mais
vraiment au milieu des vaches
j'ai appris à faire du tracteur avant de
conduire une voiture à semer des graines
dans les champs avant d'apprendre les
arrondissements paris à pêcher des
têtards avec mathilde amant de choper
maladroitement des garçons et enfiler
des bottes pleines de gadoue avant de
mettre des talons bien cirées mais j'ai
enlevé aussitôt je vous rassure
sont vraiment en avoir conscience j'ai
eu une enfance bercée par les choses les
plus précieuses d'une vie la nature
l'authenticité et la simplicité
c'est en rejoignant la ville pour mes
études que j'ai pris l'ampleur de cette
chance
c'est en m'éloignant de la nature que
j'ai compris dont elle était
indispensable
mon équilibre et pour l' équilibre de
chacun d'entre nous
c'est en étant confronté au monde du
paraître et en essayant maladroitement
me conformer je me suis perdu moi même
les boîtes de nuit les baskets dernier
cri le maquillage bien tracé et les
jolies photos instagram j'ai foncé tête
baissée dans ce monde que l'on me
présenter comme la normalité
comme vous peut-être j'ai pensé que me
conformer était un passage obligé pour
trouver ma place dans ce monde
alors j'ai laissé mes bottes chez mes
parents à la ferme pour enfiler mes cinq
fils aimé slim j'ai troqué les graines
dans les champs par mes cahiers trop
bien rangée et j'ai commencé à jouer un
rôle celui de la fille parfaite ferait
plaisir à tout le monde en décrochant le
meilleur job est le plus beau petit
copain j'ai enchaîné les 20 sur 20 les
majors de promotion les félicitations
qui se traduisait par des émirats loin
cette petite bravo continuer à bien
travailler
en moi j'étais en dissonance cognitive
pourquoi m'obstiner à porter une blouse
du chili alors que je rêve de dévorer
les livres
pourquoi m'acharner a si bien travaillé
et puis aller loin dans la vie ça veut
dire quoi c'est quoi réussir ça d
attendre que les choix les événements
soient dictées par d'autres avoir son
bac mention très bien pour suivre une
voie toute tracée
ou signer le contrat d'une vie
rectiligne belle maison avec piscine
dressing fille déborde mec blond aux
yeux bleus et plonge bien remplie
famille heureuse
est ce que vraiment j'ai envie de ça est
ce que toi tu aspires à cette villa
pour y répondre et pour éviter le burn
out à 40 ans ou les regrets 60 ans j'ai
voulu me trouvais
définir ma propre l'option de la
réussite
qui suis-je
est ce qu'un jour on nous a posé la
question à l'école est ce que toi tu
sais qui tu es est ce que tu t'es posé
la question avant de savoir ce que tu
voulais faire comme métier
ou y répondre je suis parti en inde à 18
ans par une force intérieure que je
n'explique pas
je me suis retrouvé dans les bidonvilles
avec les enfants ils y vivent d'amour et
de sourire
j'ai découvert la vraie richesse celle
qui ne se traduit pas par une course
toujours plus
j'ai connu l'amour inconditionnel la
définition authentique du partage et du
vivre ensemble
j'ai plongé dans ce que l'humanité avait
de plus beau loin de tout conformisme
loin de la comparaison loin des idéaux
loin des futilités j'ai touché à la
vraie vie
c'est comme si tu jour au lendemain tu
avait plongé dans la vie des grands
j'avais naïvement cru que la voie royale
vers le succès était celle de
l'accumulation de biens matériels
et ce voyage a déconstruit des années
certitude
j'ai compris que le bonheur ne dépendait
que de nous
l'on pouvait ne pas avoir assez à manger
et dormir sous un toit en bâche et
pourtant sourire plus dans un lit bordés
cuillère en argent dans la bouche
de pris une sacrée claque et mon retour
en france a été assez brutales
comment continuer à jouer un rôle dans
une société que l'on trouve soi même
bancale
fini de faire plaisir aux autres fini
les amis qui n'en sont pas fini le vodka
red bull que je n'ai jamais aimé pidgin
tout neuf qui viennent de chine pini
l'utopie place à la brévine à celle que
l'on n'a pas prévu d' avance pour moi à
celle des sauts dans le vide et des
landes vie à celle des échecs et des
rebonds à celle des projets d aventure
l avis qui n'est pas lisse et 10 pts et
contrôlée bref la sosso dans l'inconnu
alors j'ai commencé à faire du tri
partout dans tous les recoins de même
des amis aux habits sont de trop des
dépenses inutiles et peur qui empêche
pour ne garder autour de moi que ce qui
compte vraiment qui contribue à mon
épanouissement et à la construction
d'une société plus harmonieuse
quand on vous posait cette fameuse
question est ce que tu veux faire plus
tard je ne cherchais plus un métier qui
paraît très bien imaginant celui qui
gagnerait le plus de pions doré et je
répondais humblement je souhaitais
impacté le monde là ma façon
alors j'ai cherché comment l'impact et
ce monde un peu naïvement j'ai commencé
à tendre un micro jeunes à des inconnus
des personnes qui m'inspire en créant
mon podcast nouvel oeil
pourtant j'avais peur
peur de ne pas être assez bien ou d'être
trop peur de me confronter au regard des
autres peur d'oser faire ce qu'il n'ait
pas présenté comme un vrai métier
peur de manquer peur de ne pas gagner ma
vie
et puis j'ai compris que la paire
m'empêcherait beaucoup de choses et le
jour où j'ai compris ça plus rien
empêché la poursuite de mes rêves
alors je me suis entouré de ce qui
comptait vraiment pour moi de mes
racines comme une promesse à moi même de
ne jamais m'éloigner de ce qui compte
vraiment et de ce qui me rend heureuse
allez à la cabane dans la forêt chez
joël hallais la danse avec matt hill
habillé dans le grenier de mamie ou
encore passer plus de temps dans la
nature à paris surtout ça
j'ai cultivé l'être avant le faire j'ai
repensé mon utilisation des réseaux
sociaux du téléphone - instagram one
story embellie plus d'authenticité de
place au moment de l'autre côté d'écran
j'ai avancé à contre courant d'un modèle
de société qui nous éloigne de nous
mêmes et je peux vous dire qu'il faut un
sacré courage aux effets durent une vie
qui n'est pas dans les clous mais de
quoi est ce qu'on se souviendra à 90 ans
est ce que tu voudras faire défiler le
film de ta propre vie celui que d'autres
ont tourné pour toi
alors chaque jour je peins nouveau ça
donne envie le sort de ma zone de
confort de quelque façon que ce soit
j'apprends être confortable dans
l'inconfortable et à croire en des
projets plus grand que moi
en 2019 à 20 ans j'ai dit un mot je vais
publier un livre et trash et de mots la
librairie à bordeaux ce à quoi on m'a
répondu ouais c'est bien beau victoria
mais tu sais les rêves faut aussi être
réaliste
trois ans après à 23 ans tu peut leur
accorder la plus belle des réponses
être réaliste c'est comprendre qu aucun
rêve n'est trop grand trop haut au plus
tôt piste ou trop peu inconscient il n'y
a que des grèves qui attendent à prendre
forme dans le réel
avec de la discipline du travail de la
persévérance parce que rien n'est simple
et c'est ce qui donne d'autant plus de
profondeur aux choses parce qu elle
lorsqu'elle se concrétise parce que oui
mon livre porte aussi en lui le poids de
galère de refus de découragement
parrainons et surtout il porte en lui la
conviction courage audace et l'humilité
alors quel que soit votre rêve planqué
quelque part je vous souhaite de passer
à l'action n'importe où quand comment
sur un coin de terre dans un tram votre
chambre à une soirée à moitié bourré ou
endormi ce qui importe c'est l'action
l'action étouffe le doute lui nos
limites
l'action new town de l'énergie lors le
doute la prend et l'action entre l
action qui fait part hier aux peurs
alors le doute est plus fait confiance
et pour la suite laissez-vous surprendre
parce que la vie c'est sûr prendre pour
lui fais confiance et quand on se fait
confiance
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de consacrer mes
journées et mes nuits parfois à la
concrétisation d'une multitude de
projets qui ont une même mission
celle de révéler les rêves d'une
génération endormi par les écrans
parce que pour soigner le monde il faut
commencer par se soigner soit
alors je tente encore maladroitement
peut-être mais je tente d'éveiller les
consciences par l'inspiration
parce que le monde a besoin de rêveurs
d'audace d'amour de bienveillance et
surtout puisque jamais de gens heureux
le bonheur est essentielle brad pour
agir sur le long terme si l'on perd
cette joie de vivre alors tout est perdu
et moi j'ai envie de croire que tout
reste à gagner
les diplômes ne valent finalement pas
grand chose ça quelqu'un d'habiter par
la vie
[Applaudissements]